gravier franchement je suis ravie
d'acquérir
merci bonjour Estelle vous allez être un
peu la marraine de cette émission
c'est fini tous les matins voilà
notamment au maquillage Estelle denier
je sais même pas si on a besoin de la
présenter parce que c'était Denis a tout
fait alors l'actu le sport le
divertissement on l'a vu chez M6
l'équipe si elle a fait toutes les
chaînes oui jusqu'à la 23 après je suis
pas là c'est vous l'animatrice de Splash
[Musique]
non mais j'aime bien les les nouveaux
projets et j'aimerais qu'on me propose
des choses donc en fait et je m'ennuie
assez vite j'ai un coefficient d'ennuis
assez fort donc voilà et en fait quand
je m'ennuie et que tout d'un coup on
propose un autre truc que j'aime et ben
je n'hésite pas à partir mais je
comprends on a retrouvé
journal de l'euro donc c'est avant
l'Euro et c'était l'Euro 2000 et oui
donc j'avais
j'avais 23 ans 23 ans Estelle il y a
beaucoup de choses qui ont qui ont bougé
je voyais déjà bah la coupe de cheveux
déjà la coupe de cheveux
on avait fait des commentaires sur votre
couple de chant elle est un peu garçon
voilà en fait c'était mon patron de
l'époque
il faut que tu te coupes les cheveux tu
comprends une fille les cheveux courts
il y a pas et c'est pas le meilleur
conseil qui m'a donné il m'a donné plein
de bons conseils après mais celui-là
ça vous va bien la coupe comme ça depuis
2021 donc Estelle midi sur RMC tous les
jours entre 12h et 15 heures on va un
extrait
on est très très heureux d'être avec
vous jusqu'à 15 heures comme chaque jour
du lundi au vendredi et aujourd'hui on
sera avec Rémi barré bonjour Rémi
bonjour Estelle et bonjour à tous on
sera avec Daniel Riolon bien sûr salut
Daniel salut tout le monde les vacances
urbent
c'était comment il y a pas longtemps je
pense c'est vraiment longtemps
ça elle rentre un petit peu plus tôt le
28 ans vous avez repris oui on a repris
le 28 août c'est ça a toujours un petit
peu avant tout le monde voilà c'est la
mise en scène
oui il y a des nouveaux chroniqueurs et
on a un humoriste aussi qui vient de
nous rejoindre qui s'appelle Vincent
cirroussi qui est tout jeune il a 27 ans
et on l'adore il est là tous les jours à
14h30 dans l'émission alors bon les
joies du direct bien sûr pour l'instant
nous on en a pas eu mais je crois que
c'est la première c'est la première
c'est ça
une technique non oui
on espère quand même que vous allez
pouvoir remporter le jackpot je fais le
32 16 jours
je vais ouvrir le coffre 32 16 parce que
la personne ne s'ouvre pas
ah non mais c'est quoi ça
[Musique]
sent le jackpot oui parce que quand on a
le maillot ça ne se grippe jamais je
reviens le 32 16 c'est le bon code vas-y
commence
on va laisser passer une très courte
page de pub Laurie on vous reprend un
truc on adore on adore franchement
Estelle on adore ça tombe toujours sur
moi ces trucs là
ce coffre il est RMC à mon avis depuis
des lustres il faut que ça tombe ce
monde vous avez ouvert ou pas
d'accord
elle a tout gagné Damien ben c'est vrai
que on se rend compte que vous faites
partie de la grille de RMC et en
regardant de plus près cette grille de
rentrée on se rend compte que vous êtes
la seule femme à porter un rendez-vous
avec Apolline de Malherbe qui anime la
matinale est-ce que RMC c'est pas un peu
radio macho quand même non parce que si
tu si tu fais le calcul Apolline elle a
deux heures moi j'ai 3 heures derrière
en fait il y a trois heures donc il y a
il y a juste avant nous il y a des
Grandes Gueules ils sont deux garçons on
va compter un ensuite derrière nous tu
as Vincent Moscato Jérôme roten puis
l'after mais en fait il y a peu de
rendez-vous sur RMC on fait beaucoup de
grosses tranches donc finalement je
pense qu'on est deux peut-être sur 5 ou
6 là je te parle en semaine parce que le
week-end et Marion Bartoli également
mais tu vois c'est finalement pas mal et
puis pardon mais vous êtes considéré
quelque part une apparence féminine
comme un mec dire que vous les tenez
parce que Riolo retennent tout ça c'est
pas des gens qui sont très faciles à
manier Moscato or vous y arrivez très
bien donc il y a et pourquoi une femme
pourrait pas alors oui on va regarder un
extrait on va voir parfois chez Estelle
de Nice à sa pulse
au contraire je défends mes valeurs
comme toi
le le symbole me gêne c'est ça me gêne
pas qu'il écrive un livre je voudrais
qu'on entende notre invité
[Rires]
c'est vrai que j'ai quand même dans
l'émission pas mal de gueulards on va
dire donc par exemple pour se faire
entendre c'est compliqué donc voilà
maintenant je dis je hurle tais-toi et
normalement ça marche assez bien
tais-toi c'est le secret bon voilà
Isabelle poser la question tout à
l'heure
tais-toi grosse voix j'ai une voix aiguë
mais ça peut
Estelle il y a des débats agité bon ça
c'est tous les jours en toute manière
donc voilà il faut regarder c'est le
midi tous les jours midi 15h des débats
JT des thèmes effectivement de société
clivant c'est animé ça marche bien
Estelle Denis exactement l'audience
l'audience tout depuis qu'elle est
arrivée
il y a des débats JT puis parfois il y a
des il y a des tensions Estelle je
voudrais qu'on vienne sur sur une
déclaration que tu avais faite sur la
haine sur les réseaux sociaux il dit que
tu lui disais je reçois mes 50 messages
de mort par jour on va en parler je
voudrais juste qu'on écoute ce que
je reçois 50 menaces de morts par jour
et pour ces menaces de morts c'est pas
300 euros c'est zéro et ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui la levée de
l'anonymat moi je suis désolé mais ces
gens et reversey bagarres elles ont moi
qui me menace de mort qui menace de
morts mes enfants ces gens-là je ne sais
pas qu'ils sont ils s'appellent mamie du
62 truc du 64 je ne sais pas qui sont et
en fait si jamais il y avait une levée
de l'anonymère ou du anonymat parce que
vous jouez sur les mots ces gens-là je
peux vous dire il vous menacerez pas de
mort ils insulteraient pas un enfant
effectivement des menaces de mort encore
ça continue moi mais oui j'en ai eu
alors après 50 j'étais un peu exagéré
mais en revanche des insultes ça c'est
pas 9 messages sur 10 des menaces etc
oui on parlait de la levée de l'anonymat
sur sur les réseaux sociaux
personnellement pour mais c'est vrai
qu'on a beaucoup de débats comme ça et
et sur RMC on a cette chance de pouvoir
parler aussi de nous c'est à dire de
donner notre avis c'est vrai que souvent
en télé ou dans les médias les
animateurs ne donnent pas leur avis et
sur RMC RMC story le l'idée c'est
justement de s'impliquer dans les débats
de pas de pas juste être et toi et toi
de donner de donner son avis au début
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de mal parce que
j'étais pas habitué et finalement j'ai
pris goût et je le donne beaucoup
peut-être trop mdr mais voilà mais j'ai
vraiment pris où c'est sympa en fait
mais oui ça marche bien oui c'est vrai
que vous y prenez goût et on le sent
mais c'est mais auparavant vous aviez
tendance j'ai cassé l'écran
le matériel est en forme
tout va bien
et c'est vrai qu'avant on vous
connaissait plus comme la madame sport
du PAF est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un
petit peu déçu d'avoir mis cette
activité entre parenthèses sachant que
cette année la France accueille la Coupe
du monde de rugby les Jeux Olympiques
vous allez être un petit peu sur le banc
de touche au moment où finalement
la planète sport va être en ébullition
ici en France bah déjà c'est mon choix
c'est moi qui ai choisi de de quitter
l'équipe après j'ai fait beaucoup de
sport dans ma carrière mais j'avais
envie d'élargir et surtout quand je suis
arrivé à RMC en fait c'est une année de
présidentielle donc il y avait ça aussi
après les Jeux Olympiques je pense les
faire également pour RMC donc je ne
serai pas sur la touche mais moi j'ai
besoin en fait de de changer de pas être
toujours dans une case ça j'ai beaucoup
de mal à rester dans le même rôle figé
et puis je trouve que l'idée de changer
d'émission de changer d'univers ça nous
pousse à chaque fois à nous renouveler
et à rechercher des trucs à se mettre en
danger et j'aime bien ça aussi alors
attends tu es passé ici
il y a pas si longtemps que ça Estelle
c'était la dernière ce soir de touche
pas à mon sport merci à tous d'avoir été
nous avec nous merci à tous les
chroniqueurs on va venez me rejoindre
merci beaucoup
merci à tous les chroniqueurs merci
au public il était un bonheur d'être
avec vous en quotidienne et on est beau
voilà c'est pour ça que je les ai fait
un peu partout
ça me bouleverse aussi
je pars je suis toujours parti en fait
en me disant mince parce que j'ai envie
de faire autre chose mais mais je quitte
des gens que j'aime voilà c'était le cas
pour l'équipe sur cette émission
[Musique]
mais oui parce qu'on s'amusait bien pour
le coup on s'amusait bien mais bon j'ai
compris aussi et puis et puis voilà et
puis après c'est la vie de la télé on
n'est pas propriétaire de sa grâce
aujourd'hui d'autant que le sport
rejoint souvent un effet divers
ça permet de
un petit jeu
ça PAF ou ça casse c'est pas de moi
d'accord
on va te montrer des vignettes tu vas
choisir des vignettes il y a des
questions derrière
[Rires]
elles sont là alors quelle vignette
choisis-tu de retourner une
c'est le ballon rouge on l'a retourne
voilà présenter une émission de foot
quand on est une femme ça passe ça casse
sans problème moi j'ai jamais eu de
soucis je l'ai fait sur M6 je l'ai fait
ici
sur le canal mais en fait comme moi je
me pose pas la question de du genre
voilà le mois à la mode en fait moi j'y
arrive je me dis pas tiens je suis une
femme et je suis entouré de mec en fait
j'arrive et je me dis bah je suis
journaliste sportif et je vais faire mon
émission et franchement moi ça m'a
jamais posé de problème au contraire
j'en ai joué aussi parce que je me je me
marrais beaucoup et je pense que ça peut
être même été un atout est-ce que
j'aurais été prise à ce rôle là sur M6
pendant tes 100% foot si j'avais été un
garçon peut-être pas en fait je pense
que M6 quand ils m'ont pris la première
fois ils se dis on va aussi faire un
coup voilà parce que c'était la chaîne
0% foot en 98 c'était un petit peu
planté un coup ils veulent faire du foot
et et ça a donné une émission
le sport le foot en général ça va être
de moins en moins parce que
ça manque mais en même temps je peux
regarder des matchs avec eux sans penser
au sujet du lendemain donc ça c'est
assez agréable et je continue à aller au
stade c'est vrai que vous avez été
précurseur pour les femmes en tout cas
vous avez donné envie à beaucoup de
femmes de faire ce métier on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui il y a des femmes
qui commentent des rencontres sportives
sur l'équipe on sait qu'il y a Candice
Roland par exemple des matchs maintenant
Roland Garros aussi une femme aussi qui
a commenté un grand match
il y en a eu beaucoup mais on se rend
compte que ça devient de plus en plus en
tout cas monnaie courante de voir des
femmes dans le sport et je pense que
vous vous êtes mais vous n'êtes pas pour
rien si c'est le cas j'en suis fière
une autre une autre question une autre
case à retourner
on va revoir laquelle
je fais dans l'ordre franchement quelle
est la pire émission laquelle tu as
participé pourquoi Flash
mais non mais splash en fait le seul
regret que j'ai aucun regret de ce que
j'ai fait il y a pas une émission que je
regrette donc mais splash en fait je me
dis l'idée d'être en robe de soirée à
cause d'une piscine c'était pas la bonne
c'est clairement j'aurais aimé plutôt
d'être à côté de la piscine non la
piscine ça allait mais en fait on s'est
bien marré mais je pense qu'on aurait pu
encore plus rire et finalement ça
marchait plutôt pas mal mais voilà on
était pour moi j'étais trop gainé
j'avais un prompteur j'ai horreur de ça
alors les rebelles prompteur là c'est
c'est sûr que ça pouvait pas bon ça
pouvait pas me plaire mais mais je
resterai aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je sais pas parce que
c'était il y a 10 ans j'étais en fait je
venais d'arriver à TF1 a priori je
venais aussi pour une émission pour
d'autres émissions et puis et puis
finalement quand on est à TF1 on est
très bien payé mais je faisais pas grand
chose donc j'avais aussi des scrupules à
dire non j'aime bien voilà mériter quand
même mon salaire mais ça m'amusait voilà
ça le concept m'amusait ça avait
cartonné au Pays-Bas et franchement
c'est bien marré les trajets c'était
énorme pour les tous le TGV on allait à
Schiltigheim à côté de Strasbourg on a
beaucoup beaucoup rigolé sur cette
émission mais ça a laissé une trace hein
la preuve c'est que c'est une des
émissions passées rétamer dans ton
souvenir encore mais pas rétamé parce
que non mais franchement regardez vos
fiches j'assure ça va bien marcher la
dernière non j'ai les deux premiers oui
qu'on en parle plus maintenant
il y a eu trois numéros donc comme vous
avez 10 ans il y a un moment oui c'est
pas le plus grand succès de c'est pas je
veux dire quand je mourrai je retienne
que ça quoi
une dernière question Estelle dernière 5
une 3e case donc la troisième c'est ça
si j'ai compris le principe mais
n'importe quoi
de Raymond direct ça passe ou ça casse
bon écoute ça passe parce que là c'était
en 2008 donc je n'ai pas répondu donc
voilà tu commandes nous sommes plus
ensemble a priori ça ne se fera plus
mais non en fait aujourd'hui à l'époque
j'en ai pas trop rigolé ça me faisait
pas marrer du tout et maintenant j'en
rigole voilà donc sur le moment tu as
été un peu saisi mais sur le moment
j'étais quand même en direct donc en
fait et l'équipe de France venait de se
faire éliminer et comme donc Raymond on
était sélectionné c'est pas une émission
facile c'est pas c'est pas la meilleure
émission et donc ça pousse la demande tu
vois il y a un moment où tu dis ça c'est
l'heure va être longue